si han sido muchas las reacciones de la
cal de eeuu entre ellas la de nancy
pelosi presidenta de la cámara
representante es que pues anunció que lo
poner la bandera de eeuu a media asta en
el congreso también la reacción ha
reaccionado el líder republicano del
senado mitch mcconnell diciendo que pues
se une al lucro del pueblo británico por
la muerte de la reina isabel michelle y
barack obama lo hicieron en un
comunicado conjunto y también hillary y
bill clinton también se sumaron a esta
lista de ex mandatarios en la que
también está jimmy carter que se suman a
este luto a esta conmemoración también y
hasta el reconocimiento de las siete
décadas que estuvo la reina isabel al
mando de la corona inglesa y de rescatar
de rescatar obviamente el comunicado
oficial que emite la casa blanca- joe
biden que dice que efectivamente fueron
siete décadas de mucho cambio que
presenció y que vivió y que influenció
y sabe el segundo dice que fue crucial
para una era dice además que
en durante sus 70 años las relaciones
entre eeuu e inglaterra se hicieron muy
fuertes ella fue una piedra angular para
la relación bilateral entre eeuu e
inglaterra lo dice en el comunicado en
este comunicado también pues resalta que
pudo reunirse con la reina isabel
durante dos ocasiones primero en 1982
cuando yo bailé el acelerador y después
en el 2021 cuando asume el liderazgo de
eeuu dice qué 14 presidentes
estadounidenses pasaron y pasaron por la
casa blanca cuando ella era reina de
eeuu y resalta el reina perdón de
inglaterra y resalta que pues la reina
isabel estuvo muy presente y mandó sus
simpatías precisamente en el 9/11 en ese
atentado a las torres gemelas en nueva
york y también en las celebraciones de
bicentenario en eeuu
en diferentes ocasiones durante este
comunicado que fue bastante extenso el
presidente joe biden reconoció el gran
trabajo del trabajo arduo el trabajo
dedicado de la reina isabel dice que
además los países del commonwealth se
fortalecieron recordemos que estos
países del commonwealth eran colonias
inglesas que después pasaba a tener
estrechos vínculos económicos y
políticos con inglaterra
de hecho resaltar que muchos de los
ciudadanos de países como canadá y
australia podían viajar a inglaterra a
hacerse tratamientos médicos porque eran
reconocidos prácticamente como
ciudadanos ingleses al último el
comunicado el presidente de bailén dice
que espera trabajar de la mano con el
príncipe carlos tercero para seguir
estrechando esta relación que ya es
bastante estrecha precisamente por el
trabajo de la reina isabel segunda entre
estados unidos e inglaterra finalizando
este este comunicado dice que pues el
legado de la reina isabel segunda que
dado mucho orgullo al pueblo británico
va a estar escrito en las páginas de la
historia no solamente en inglaterra sino
en todo